Speaker 1: Having said that, I want to talk a
little bit more about my impatience, because I
do have a lot of impatience right now. And nearly
all of it is directed at Attorney General Merrick
Garland. Merrick Garland as ag as the top law
enforcement official here in the United States,
has so far not gone after Donald Trump in any
kind of meaningful way. Sure, the fake elector
investigation is obviously leading up to Trump.
It has to. I mean, he's the guy at the top of it.
But we have had plenty of people, including those
serving on the January six committee, by the way.
So this isn't just maybe an impatient this is also
people on the committee saying, hi, we've got all
of this wonderful material for you. Could you do
something? And what has been Merrick Garland's
response? Well, as he told us last week from
watching the hearings. Mm hmm. I'm watching him.
We're paying attention. So the attorney general
of the United States is out there telling us like,
don't worry, folks. I'm tuning in to
CNN every day, just like you. No, no,
no. That's. That's not good, Merrick. I don't want
you to be learning this stuff the same way that I
am. Okay. Again, you're the attorney general.
You you should probably, I don't know, maybe
be present in the room. I mean, I'm sure they'd
be willing to give you a pass to go sit in the
room while they're doing the hearings. And if not,
you probably know somebody that could get you one.
You know, if we don't want the attorney general
to sit there and say, oh, don't worry, folks,
I'm watching TV just like the rest of you. Well,
that's wonderful. If we're talking about the
season of Miss Marvel that's currently
on, but we're talking about the January
six committee hearings. You should already know
what's happening. There should be sharing of
information. Maybe that's on Garland. Maybe that's
on the committee. But the bottom line is that
they have already and the judges, of course, have
confirmed this and we've talked about it. David
talked about it. Everybody's talked about it.
The judges who've looked at this have already
said there's evidence of criminal behavior here
right now. Right now we have it. We've got it.
But Merrick Garland so far has not opened up a
single investigation into Donald Trump himself for
his actions here. And that is forever frustrating.
And to me, there's no excuse for that.
No excuse. The January six committee is only
going to be able to continue doing their job for
a couple more months. Eventually they will have
to kind of put it on pause so they can all go
and campaign. I mean, they're in the house. They
all have to campaign except for the, you know,
folks that aren't running anymore and they're
leaving after this. So they're gone anyway.
And Republicans, unfortunately, are poised to
take back over the House of Representatives.
They've made it clear they do. That committee
is over with. So what Garland should do and I
know I pitch this I think the last time I guest
host that on David's show here back in December.
But Merrick Garland should have
already appointed a special prosecutor.
That's all you need. You give them
the time, you give them the budget,
you give them the funds, you give them whatever
they need, but most importantly, you give it time
because the January six committee does not have
time. The January six committee has wasted so much
time having to go to court to battle these people
who don't want to comply with the subpoenas.
A special prosecutor wouldn't have that problem,
right? A grand jury wouldn't have that problem.
It would be so much easier for a special
prosecutor to be appointed by Merrick Garland
to walk into that January six committee and
say, listen, you guys have done phenomenal work.
I'm going to take it from here. Thank you
for everything you've done. Thank you for
everything you've given us. But I've got this.
Don't worry. And in fact, appoint two or three
special prosecutors. There's a bunch of different
avenues, bunch of different schemes that do need
to be investigated. And it'd be great to have a
separate person on each and every one of them.
Folks. I've been screaming about that for eight,
nine months now. And we still haven't gotten it.
And the only person standing in the way of that
is, of course, unfortunately, the attorney general
of the United States, Merrick Garland. We cannot
have any. Any forward progress without his say so